Caption: hello hello welcome welcome to DDD so
Caption: kick off today I like to introduce you
Caption: to Andrew and Andrews gonna talk to you
Caption: today Andrew from Perth I'm a dad he's
Caption: going to talk to you today about UX
Caption: design and VR and AR so without further
Caption: any further ado here's Andrew thank you
Caption: so can everyone is that too loud that's
Caption: good okay so I'm gonna be trying to
Caption: tease out the difference between the
Caption: hype about VR and the reality of where
Caption: it might go and what that means to a UX
Caption: community now the I did a little
Caption: research so the average age of people in
Caption: this room is apparently 32 years old now
Caption: the question is how long are you
Caption: planning to be working and according to
Caption: these statistics it'll be another half a
Caption: century so just imagine the kind of
Caption: changes that are going to occur during
Caption: your career and that's really the kind
Caption: of big perspective I want to bring to
Caption: this talk so to put in the in law in a
Caption: in the for the purposes of presenting
Caption: that context a little trip back in the
Caption: history so most of what we have was
Caption: already being prototypes in the 1960s
Caption: and at the same time as that there was
Caption: this big explosion in science fiction
Caption: and a lot of that was about augmentation
Caption: and how technology could enhance the
Caption: experience of being human some of that
Caption: was very negative but a lot of it was
Caption: very optimistic and that's the dream of
Caption: computer science is that we can remember
Caption: more find out more things communicate
Caption: more quickly that we can have new ways
Caption: to create and have new experiences so
Caption: that's that's been the great dream and a
Caption: part of that was new ways to see and
Caption: what we're looking at here is a 1968
Caption: very early augmented reality system
Caption: now during the 1980s that utopian idea
Caption: became very very strong in popular
Caption: culture and I'm sure you're all familiar
Caption: with both of these intellectual
Caption: properties and they've had an enormous
Caption: impact on our perception about how the
Caption: future will be and of course people who
Caption: like to work with computers are probably
Caption: even more involved with this kind of pop
Caption: culture than the average person
Caption: yes we're all nerds we're all here in
Caption: the room we can we can say that but what
Caption: was what was what's very cool about it
Caption: is that they are absolutely anticipating
Caption: things up here in the top left
Caption: Doc Brown has got some augmented reality
Caption: sunglasses might be the cheapest prop in
Caption: the history of science fiction but
Caption: that's in the story what they do and
Caption: here's a virtual reality experience and
Caption: then of course there's a holodeck from
Caption: Star Trek which gave a view of virtual
Caption: reality that was so so futuristic that
Caption: in point of fact it was dangerous you
Caption: could be killed in a virtual reality and
Caption: so forth and so on so this has really
Caption: informed our idea about virtual reality
Caption: and it has become this idea of the
Caption: head-mounted display has become iconic
Caption: of our progression through technology
Caption: iconic of technological advancement
Caption: after the Second World War and that's a
Caption: problem and so here we are so this is
Caption: much more recent this is now and yet we
Caption: still have this incredible image of
Caption: someone wearing a very high-tech head
Caption: mounted display or goggles or whatever
Caption: you want to call it and they're reaching
Caption: forth into the future always from right
Caption: to left for some composition or graphic
Caption: design reason it's like a standard and
Caption: they're reaching out to the grid the
Caption: mesh the cyberpunk
Caption: cyber future mesh so it's very powerful
Caption: and this has existed for as long as
Caption: probably all of us have been alive and
Caption: certainly has existed for that all all
Caption: the time that all of us have been
Caption: professionals in this field
Caption: so a trip back to when I didn't have a
Caption: gray hair in fact I used to have red
Caption: hair and so this is for achoo a Latino
Caption: virtuality is famous in VR history it
Caption: was the first publicly available VR
Caption: experience that was even in the ballpark
Caption: of of a working system and I was walking
Caption: through a video arcade in London in 1992
Caption: and so you can imagine my complete
Caption: delight when I came across this no this
Caption: was my hover board moment I thought I
Caption: have arrived in the future so it was no
Caption: problem for me to shell out the
Caption: equivalent of xxx $30 now to get into
Caption: this and so I'm gonna the appropriate
Caption: way to describe the experience I had was
Caption: that it was a experience that's not
Caption: that's not official ux talk but that's
Caption: the experience I had I had I had motion
Caption: sickness I didn't even understand what I
Caption: was doing there was a video game in
Caption: there and I have since doing research
Caption: discovered that it was almost certainly
Caption: dactyl nightmare and it was named dactyl
Caption: nightmare because it was a multiplayer
Caption: first-person shooter in which there was
Caption: also the added bonus of a pterodactyl
Caption: who would sweep down pick you up and
Caption: kill you so I got through my $25 worth
Caption: of being killed without even realizing
Caption: that was what was happening because the
Caption: image resolution you see here is on a
Caption: monitor that's not what you saw in the
Caption: headset so it was just a lot of very
Caption: laggy blurry pixels and so I am an
Caption: affirmed VR skeptic so by 1995 Nintendo
Caption: had demonstrated an enormous cost and
Caption: embarrassment that VR was not going to
Caption: happen in retail domestic game
Caption: environments
Caption: their worst ever selling console
Caption: although they're now worth quite a lot
Caption: of money so if you have one in the retro
Caption: market retro nostalgia market they
Caption: they're big so there's all of these
Caption: problems with VR these are the alleged
Caption: reasons why we going laser pointer sorry
Caption: about that but the most people say that
Caption: the problem here is that there's an
Caption: issue with the low resolution and the
Caption: latency and the lack of good content
Caption: that people don't play them the games
Caption: are the experiences because the content
Caption: is not compelling enough which means
Caption: there's no market which means no one
Caption: will spend the money to improve all the
Caption: issues with lag and latency I don't
Caption: believe that if you do a first
Caption: principles UX analysis of what's going
Caption: on here with the eye that argument
Caption: doesn't stand up and I'm hoping to
Caption: convince you about that today now what
Caption: has happened since I was a broken young
Caption: man in a gaming arcade in London is all
Caption: of this shit's happened now this we are
Caption: very very familiar with this is the
Caption: world we live in this has changed our
Caption: reality has changed everything about the
Caption: way we live all those products and
Caption: experiences have happened now this is
Caption: science fiction this is stuff that we
Caption: did not imagine would be happening only
Caption: 30 years ago it was in science fiction
Caption: but we didn't think it would actually
Caption: happen to us now we've been doing this
Caption: for so long it's almost become a cliche
Caption: to talk about it now VR has the
Caption: fundamental characteristic that excludes
Caption: the real world to allow immersion but
Caption: actually we do that all the time
Caption: anyway when you listen to music or read
Caption: a book or our on the phone talking to
Caption: someone or are just having a flight of
Caption: imagination you are creating immersion
Caption: which doesn't have to come with the
Caption: enormous burden of of the hardware an AR
Caption: has the fundamental characters that
Caption: overlays layers and we're doing that all
Caption: the time and all the digital media we're
Caption: already working
Caption: with already does that as well so where
Caption: I'm getting to with this is that the
Caption: fundamental problem with VR is that it
Caption: doesn't value add you know head mounted
Caption: displays do not make for a better
Caption: experience in any way and that's why
Caption: people don't want them not because of
Caption: low resolution okay so that so we're
Caption: moving on to the current VR bloom and
Caption: we're still here with this iconic thing
Caption: but to demonstrate very compellingly I
Caption: hope that nobody wants VR it's not a
Caption: value add proposition is the experience
Caption: of sunny now sunny have produced a
Caption: Playstation gaming system since the
Caption: 1990s the most the current version is
Caption: the PlayStation 4 they've sold hundreds
Caption: million units three years after they
Caption: launched that they started selling so
Caption: this was a $400 PlayStation and then
Caption: three years ago they started selling the
Caption: $400 VR extension now four million units
Caption: would make most people happy but I can
Caption: assure you that Sony will not be
Caption: impressed with only 4% of people who
Caption: bought a PlayStation taking up the VR
Caption: headset I'm prepared to bet that most of
Caption: those VR headsets are now in the same
Caption: box as all the unused mobile phones that
Caption: we've all got at home and all the spare
Caption: internet connection cables it hasn't
Caption: taken off and if sunny can't do it with
Caption: that installed base it's not a real
Caption: thing to me that was the test point okay
Caption: but what has happened is this gigantic
Caption: event which is that Facebook went
Caption: bonkers and spent three billion dollars
Caption: buying out a small startup company who
Caption: had sold almost no product and didn't
Caption: even believe their thing they were
Caption: selling was yet a finished product
Caption: now does that mean that the VR the
Caption: domestic home retail VR entertainment
Caption: market is a real thing that's going to
Caption: happen well no because organizations
Caption: like Facebook have got more money than
Caption: God and they've got to do something with
Caption: it now this is happening to us it's our
Caption: fault because we watched all of those
Caption: ads which all of this money was earned
Caption: from on all that social media and that's
Caption: why they've got this money but what's
Caption: happening here is that organizations
Caption: that sighs have got to do something to
Caption: own the future market Facebook's under
Caption: enormous pressure from other competitors
Caption: now facing possible government control
Caption: and so they and that that long list of
Caption: other people who are moving into it are
Caption: now in a titanic war to own what may be
Caption: the future I'm just going to go back
Caption: here because now the other thing is that
Caption: most of those organizations are big
Caption: enough to put this money into VR for a
Caption: very simple reason they can afford to
Caption: lose it but whatever comes out of this
Caption: they will have developed an enormous
Caption: number of new IPS technology and
Caption: software which they will then utilize in
Caption: future so for them it's a great big
Caption: gamble stroke experiment which will
Caption: probably work out they're not going to
Caption: go bust out of this and that means that
Caption: all of those technical problems with VR
Caption: headsets and AR headsets will be solved
Caption: there won't be any more problems Thank
Caption: You Derek
Caption: okay so what does that mean to us in the
Caption: UX business well the people who are
Caption: going to have the money to pay for these
Caption: incredibly high-tech headsets and so
Caption: forth and so on are not individuals it's
Caption: corporations it's the same market we're
Caption: already working with people
Caption: organizations who can afford
Caption: we've got perfectly good economic
Caption: rationale for why they need to solve
Caption: these problems
Caption: so the value add that head-mounted
Caption: displays whether it's VR or a our offer
Caption: to me is not higher resolution it's that
Caption: it's hands-free and that's critically
Caption: important in a whole range of very
Caption: important industries
Caption: where you for safety reasons and
Caption: mobility reasons and because people are
Caption: doing stuff with their hands that's the
Caption: real value add now the really
Caption: interesting thing about this area here
Caption: is that hands-free is going to
Caption: dramatically and radically change the
Caption: way you eyes have to be this is not
Caption: going to be the hamburger icon in the
Caption: top right hand screen in your vision
Caption: these are cognitively demanding
Caption: environments so these are going to have
Caption: to be voice but voice won't work if
Caption: you're in a noisy environment gesture
Caption: but that won't work if you're gonna use
Caption: your hands possibly face movements
Caption: possibly eye tracking and then
Caption: excitingly and scarily at the same time
Caption: brain computer interfaces now I did some
Caption: research about this other weird scary
Caption: dystopian science fiction thing and I
Caption: regret to tell you it is a thing it is
Caption: really happening it's come out of
Caption: research about how to repair damaged
Caption: nerves and so basically this is gonna be
Caption: either like heart monitor pads on you
Caption: and now what's going to make that
Caption: possible for your thoughts of that
Caption: simple direction and selection is AI so
Caption: AI is going to be able to filter out of
Caption: the noise of your body that kind of
Caption: information and then the other big value
Caption: out that's going to make these headsets
Caption: very interesting to industry is AI more
Caption: generally so it's going to be able to do
Caption: all of those things and that's going to
Caption: make for a very very powerful
Caption: combination so what I'm basically saying
Caption: here is that in the entertainment world
Caption: in the domestic particular the domestic
Caption: in games area people are not going to be
Caption: watching TV
Caption: with head mounted displays it doesn't
Caption: value-add and that's probably good for
Caption: us because it means our traditional
Caption: clients are going to be employing us to
Caption: do this stuff so I'm just going to run
Caption: through very quickly through how I
Caption: imagine this is a kind of scenario so
Caption: I've chosen what it's like to be an
Caption: ambulance crew you're first responding
Caption: to some awful incident and let's just
Caption: say it's a car crash
Caption: this is obviously highly cognitively
Caption: difficult and what's different for
Caption: ambulance and paramedics is that they're
Caption: turning up to a real-world location
Caption: completely outside the control space of
Caption: a hospital they never know what they're
Caption: going to find so this is exactly the
Caption: kind of environment where you would love
Caption: it if you had some kind of head mounted
Caption: display that allowed you to work with
Caption: your hands and it was assisting you
Caption: without getting in your face so there is
Caption: no interface visually but it's checking
Caption: it's identifying things in the object
Caption: identifying hazards and communicating
Caption: information like for example you arrive
Caption: at an accident and you find the ID of
Caption: the person or even face recognize them
Caption: this happens automatically and you
Caption: simply show the driver's license for a
Caption: moment in your field of view knowing
Caption: that the AI has already worked out who
Caption: that person is and is currently calling
Caption: up their medical records to find out
Caption: what they're allergic to what
Caption: pre-existing conditions they have you're
Caption: making your assessment and you need
Caption: merely need to speak that assessment and
Caption: that assessment is now being transmitted
Caption: to the nearest hospital where this
Caption: patient will be transported once they're
Caption: stabilized buying more time making that
Caption: hospital more ready but additionally
Caption: what these systems would do they would
Caption: allow the the user the other person at
Caption: risk to be assessed for stress and so
Caption: forth and so on okay
Caption: so we're at the end of this talk now so
Caption: basically the challenges facing us are
Caption: those things a lot of this hardware is
Caption: still in its very early stages but it is
Caption: definitely coming the amount of money
Caption: that's being thrown at this means it
Caption: will happen and the question that you've
Caption: now got to ask yourself apart from how
Caption: long are you going to be in this
Caption: business is what are you going to do
Caption: when your client comes back from a
Caption: meeting with someone else who's been
Caption: talking about this stuff and they say
Caption: can you do that thank you very much
Caption: [Applause]